il ressemble à n'importe quel domicile
un salon une salle de jeux pour enfants
une chambre et une salle de bain
pourtant cette maison est un accueil de
jour dédié aux femmes victimes de
violences une structure opéré par
l'association la nouvelle étoile
objectif mettre en sécurité les familles
victimes vous avez en bas et une salle
d'esthétique qu'on a équipé au niveau
bas de soins de soins que ce soit des
soins de demain du soin du cheveu du
maquillage l'habillage et ses eaux les
femmes qui sont victimes de violence
pour venir être accompagné par un
professionnel soit de coiffure soins
d'esthétique pour prendre soin d'elle
pour reprendre de la confiance et pour
travailler aussi l'estiment de soi il se
sentir femme à part entière en plus
d'une sécurité des personnes accueillies
sont aidé un accompagnement social
médical judiciaire ou encore
psychologique situé à versailles cette
maison est la propriété du bailleur
social les résidences yvelines essonne
c'est un logement qu'on propose à la
location avec du coup un tarif
particulier un conte a sorti nous de
notre parc de commercialisation pour le
transformer le cas l'associatif donc
avec des tarifs qui sont complètement
différents beaucoup plus avantageux pour
justement aider l'association sur cette
partie à ce type de structure s'inscrit
dans le renforcement de la politique de
l'état pour lutter contre les violences
conjugales on prend soin de les
localiser en général dans des villes à
proximité des transports en commun dans
des endroits accessibles ce qui est le
cas ici à versailles puisque c'est un
accueil de jour qui est situé à la fois
dans une zone pavillonnaire à un très
familial très chaleureuse et à proximité
de toutes les commodités et des
transports dans les yvelines 11 espaces
d'accueil de jour dédié aux femmes
victimes de violence sont actuellement
ouverts